a large cache of leaked documents
exposes the offshore tax secrets of the
world's rich and famous it includes
alleged ties between a member of
president Trump's cabinet and Russian
money Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross
reportedly has a stake in a company that
does business with a gas producer partly
owned by president Putin's son-in-law
other top administration officials had
links to tax havens Julianna Goldman is
in Washington with what the so called
paradise papers reveal Julianna good
morning good morning well the paradise
papers reveal offshore investments held
by the Queen of England and several
members of President trumps cabinet most
notably Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross
and his ties to a company linked to the
Kremlin our plan will bring back
trillions of dollars from offshore
triggers the president pitched bringing
in money from offshore tax havens just
last week as part of his tax reform plan
four trillion dollars that will come
pouring back into our country from the
president's chief economic adviser Gary
Cohn to Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
and Treasury secretary Steve minuchin
the paradise' papers reveal some of the
top officials in the White House have
had offshore investments you did it to
avoid any conflicts of interest correct
that is correct sir
but it's Trump's Commerce Secretary
whose personal wealth may benefit from
firms linked to the Kremlin according to
the papers before Wilbur Ross joined the
president's cabinet he divested his
interests in a tea company but the
leaked documents reportedly show Ross
still holds indirect investments in a
shipping company called navigator
Holdings that company transports gas for
Sieber a Russian energy firm owned in
part by a Russian oligarch subject to
American sanctions and Vladimir Putin's
son-in-law
never met them don't know the people
have nothing to do with the negotiation
of the charter arrangement Ross said
this morning that he was fully honest in
his confirmation proceedings because he
was not an investor in ceebar he says he
did not need to disclose the links to
the Kremlin there was nothing wrong with
anything that was done CBS News has not
independently verified
the paradise papers which were obtained
by a German newspaper they also
reportedly show that Russia invested
millions of dollars in Facebook and
Twitter through a business associate of
Jared Kushner the president's son-in-law
and senior advisor Gale all right Thank
You Giuliana